regardez ce qu'on a là ça ça c'est quoi
ça c'est le one plus vous avez vu sacrée
derrière c'est le dix pros il est là
alors il n'a pas encore été sorti
officiellement en france en tout cas
mais il est déjà présent à barcelone où
on peut le regarder on peut le prendre
en main on peut venir le voir au plus
touché et ça ça me plaît beaucoup en
tout cas c'est vachement bien alors on
va profiter de cette avant-première en
étant sur le salon pour venir le
découvrir pour voir quelles promesses il
raconte voir un peu ce qu'on peut faire
avait commencé à rentrer un peu dans les
paramètres de la photo vous montrer et
vous annoncer la fiche technique alors
on la connaît déjà le circulent sur le
web gagne évidemment mais là le fait de
la boxe est une vraie chance est
vraiment chouette regarder ce que vous
savez où en plus c'est très tech traître
était qu'ils vont vraiment proposer des
specs un tarif super intéressant qu'on
va regarder ce qu'on a aujourd'hui de ce
que raconte ce one + 10 pro et on y va
maintenant
[Musique]
regarder ça est-ce que ça c'est pas
super mignon est ce que ça c'est pas
super beau j'adore ce design vous savez
depuis l'année dernière one place ils
ont leur module photo qui est développé
en partenariat avec castle blade alors
la seule baisse et pas n'importe qui et
en plus de ça je sais pas si vous avez
suivi ils se sont rapprochés de l'opo
c'est le même groupe à la base mais il
ya un vrai rapprochement on y voit au
niveau de la r&d et quand one pluzz
s'est rapproché des eaux pourrait bien
en place a ramené à seul blake
directement chez au pot c'est pour ça
que sur les finepix cinq pros vous avez
un seul mail et ça c'est vachement bien
on est un smartphone que je trouve
vraiment bon j'adore ce design j'adore
ce blog photo on retrouve l'esprit
douanes place au niveau de l'écran avant
je vous le montre lg vous le détailler
un petit peu mais c'est vrai que je
trouve qu'ils ont fait un super boulot
et ça c'est vraiment chouette il est
sortir de couleur ça s'élevèrent jamais
assez un vert mat qui feront pas les
traces de doigts qui est vachement sympa
l'or ici on va venir prendre les traces
de doigts au niveau du module là on voit
bien qui assurera seul blade sur le côté
on est un smartphone qui est pas trop
lourd qui fait à peine 200 g corning
gorilla glass virtus à l'avant pour
venir le protège et bien évidemment on
va retrouver à s'assécher wyplosz cette
petite partie qui vous permet d'activer
ou de désactiver le vibreur ou la
sonnerie donc on retrouve vraiment cette
partie là qu'un petit côté grippe sous
le doigt qui est très sympa le bouton
pour venir l'allumé pour l'étain le
bouton pour le volume sur le côté votre
caméra qui est planqué ici sur le dessus
globalement pas grand chose si ce n'est
un micro pour la réduction de bruit et
puis sur le bas bien évidemment de la
recharge en usb ses tiroirs de karting
avec double carte sim 5g le micro le
haut parleur ici et puis et bien
évidemment en écran l'écran si on est un
smartphone sans écran c'est qu'on n'a
pas de smartphone et puis si on n'a pas
de smartphone on peut pas en parler mais
là on en parle pour un écran fluide à
molette c'est du ltp ou alors elles tpe
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
allez avoir un taux de rafraîchissement
variable vous à venir switcher alors ici
j'ai pas l'info mais ça doit être
probablement dû passer de 1 er ce
jusqu'à 120 m on va les voir dans les
paramètres
c'est ça c'est un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 m je pense que
si je viens fouiller dans displayed
brightness je vais trouver l'information
alors regardez on a une résolution qhd
plus on le voit ici tu vois je n'ai plus
à venir consommer davantage au niveau de
la batterie mais ça c'est à vous de voir
pour y mettre aussi en automatique comme
on est sur le salon ils l'ont poussé en
qhd plus pour qu'on montre le maximum et
puis vous le voyez si au niveau du taux
de rafraîchissement 120 hertz ou alors
on peut rester au standard en 61 c'est
un très grand classique une fois qu'on
connaît ici chez one pleut qu'est ce
qu'on voit également et bien on a des
plans qui fait 6,7 pouces 1 milliard de
couleurs certifié hdr 10 plus
l'expérience logiciel c'est oxygène eau
s est basé sur un android 12 alors c'est
assez marrant parce que là je trouve que
c'est très monochrome ce qu'on vient
voir ici voyez ces blancs ces bleus j'ai
connu un peu plus de deux fantaisies
peut-être qu'on peut venir personnalisé
mais ça je vous le dirai lorsqu on
testera ultérieurement là c'est vraiment
une première prise en main est une
première découverte parce qu on se le
rappelle que ce produit n'a toujours pas
été lancé toujours pas en france c'est
une vraie chance il vrai avant première
au niveau de l'audio on sait que
l'action avoir des haut parleurs stéréo
une fois de plus s'en reparlera lors du
test bluetooth 5.2 pour venir à péret
des écouteurs très facilement puis
surtout et c'est ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'ici on a un instinct dragonne 8
jean one on va avoir beaucoup de
performances a toujours été ce que fait
de façon à one peut aussi si vous avez
de la rame soit 8 gigas de ram soit 12
giga de ram c'est la lpddr2 5 et puis
soit 128 jia de stockage soit 256 est
ici non extensible toute façon en place
il ne permet pas de venir augmenter le
stockage donc rien de bien nouveau ici
tout en sachant que vous avez une grosse
batterie de 5000 milliampères heures à
l'intérieur avec de la recharge rapide
filaire 80 watts et puis la recharge
sans fil 50 watts et au niveau de la
photo on a quoi en config et bien on va
voir un grand-angle de 48 mégapixels on
parle vraiment un partenarait castle
blind donc je vais vous montrer quelques
images va venir jeter quelques trucs
vous allez voir 48 mégapixels et ouvre à
f 1.8 on a également un ultra
grand-angle de 50 méga pixels tout bref
deux points depuis un tel objectif de 8
mégapixels avec un zoom optique x 3,3
couvre f 2.4 ils pouvaient faire la
vidéo ici le regarde et on va venir ici
regardez vous le voyez là je suis en
couleurs 10 bits couleurs d'emile ça
veut dire que je vais venir chuté en 10
bits et ça va s'afficher en 10 bits sur
mon écran seo pour qui vous propose la
même chose on vient appuyer là on va
compter sur un zoom optique x 3 3 on
voit qu'il ya la star il ya une vraie
stable là dessus et avec moi croyez moi
c'est très important votre
ultra-grand-angle en fois 06 et puis on
peut venir filmer jusqu'à 8 ya alors ça
va être de 8 à 30 images pas même passé
de 8 à 24 images par seconde je pensais
30 et même pas ayant quatre cas je peux
monter jusqu'à 120 images par seconde
pour vous dire que leur préfèrent des
ralentis plutôt sympa 60 ou également 30
donc franchement de quoi faire en termes
de config photos et vidéos vous avez
bien évidemment sur ce smartphone du
wifi 6 il est certifié ip 68 et puis les
tarifs gagne évidemment il est dispo on
les a pas alors il va être annoncée je
pense en mars je vous en dirai plus sur
le tarif sur la dispo mais c'est vrai
que là j'adore l'écran incurvé je trouve
hyper canon je trouve qu'il a une très
bonne prise en main garder je fais un
tour assez facilement il est long on
n'est pas très épais bien qu'il fasse
ses 200 g je trouve pas l'eau le poids
est bien réparti je trouve vraiment
hyper calme j'aime beaucoup vraiment je
peux dire que là dessus one flo ça très
très très bien bossé très jolie
smartphones on va regarder ce qu'ils ont
fait au niveau software au niveau de la
photo parce que c'est vraiment ça qui va
nous intéresser c'est ce partenariat
avec castle blake parce que l'année
dernière c'est déjà bien là quand je
vois le boulot café au port sur les
failles de cinq pros qui est vraiment
juste énorme au niveau de la photo on en
reparlera très bientôt de finding cinq
pros dont vous le verrez donc j'imagine
que là-dessus également one place a dû
extrêmement bien travaillé avec à des
clichés probablement un peu plus typé on
verra on regardera ça en tout cas sur le
papier tout ça extrêmement alléchant le
smartphone je trouve beau et j'ai très
hâte mais extrêmement hâte de pouvoir
tester et d'aller beaucoup plus loin du
regard des autres et quelques petites
photos comme ça hop là on vient pour la
com ça va venir comparer alors bon on a
des choses un peu dans le plan qui sont
pas ouf mais c'est comme ça c'est les
conditions donc là on peut monter en x
3,3 et regardez je peux monter jusqu'au
juin fois cinq là ok j'ai 1 x 10 ok et
joue à alger jusqu'à oulalala et pique
un peu le vôtre un pur de toute façon va
pas aller aussi loin on va s'en garder
le résultat tout de suite mon le x 30 je
pense que on va oublier alors je penses
toi tu sont des mises à jour au niveau
logiciel donc ce qu'on voit là c'est
vraiment un premier jet et puis les
conditions sont pas évidentes sur le
salon il ya plein de lumière et s'est
pas complètement ouf bon c'est un
aquarium très honnêtement c'est pas
possible de juger c'est vraiment
histoire de se faire un premier jet se
marrent l ultra grand-angle je ne trouve
pas déformant donc plutôt de suite au
intéressant le x 3 optique c'est très
compliqué de venir se prononcer et
chantereine film hanna corium ya du vert
devant donc on verra pas grand chose le
x 5 me paraît pas mal la qualité ne
semble pas être dégradés et d'envoyer
dès qu'on arrive sur les x 10 sait déjà
c'est pas au fond c'est pas au fait des
fautes quand on oublie mais bon voilà on
regardera ça parce que c'est vraiment le
sujet qui vient nous intéresser ici bien
évidemment toute la partie vidéo on
regardera ça également on peut switcher
comment ça se passe au niveau software
est ce que des nouveautés non c'est la
même chose semble pas qu'ils aient de
grandes nouveautés j'ai pas l'impression
que ce nom c'est plutôt bien fait on
voit un peu la transition entre les
objectifs mais rien de surprenant la
caméra de saïfi fait de voir ça raconte
quoi coucou je suis là il ya un tracking
on le voit au niveau de mon visage donc
reconnaissance c'est pas mal mais
attention c'est vraiment fou parce que
en règle générale ce que vous voyez là
c'est que les écrans sont tellement bien
optimisé que il faut vraiment voir les
fichiers sur un ordinateur pour se
rendre compte donc c'est strictement
impossible de pouvoir se rendre compte
tout de suite on va être un peu plus
large ici ok ça marche alors j'ai vu sur
la partie photo regarder on peut venir
le push est en sommeil en ail et là on
pousse directement le 48 mégapixels un
mode portrait morges voir une expo
longer le mode span exactement sa soul
blade en vacances c'est leur format qui
est vraiment vraiment cool comme ce que
vous retrouverez notamment sur le fameux
dic cinq pros et puis un mode nuit
of course et avec un mode trépied c'est
un peu le même principe que l'on trouve
chez au pot et je pense que de toute
façon c'est là où on voit vraiment la
mutualisation au niveau des marques au
niveau du r&d au niveau software parce
que je pense qu'à terme de toute façon
oxygène os va disparaître au profit de
colons et ça me paraîtrait assez logique
il ya un tel rapprochement que je
comprendrais pas pourquoi est-ce que
johan cruijff garde une expérience
logiciels qu'ils soient un peu
différente en tout cas je trouve ça
plutôt intéressant et c'est prometteur
on testera ça et on verra ça bien
évidemment un peu plus tard je suis très
heureux d'avoir pu vous présenter
aujourd'hui ce produit avant même son
lancement en france est assez
extraordinaire c'est assez unique
s'annonce vraiment le positionnement des
marques de se dire on veut parler de ce
smartphone on a besoin de faire parler
nous on a besoin de montrer ce qu'on est
capable de faire donc ce qui fait qu'on
se retrouve une situation qui sont un
peu particulière et je pense que c est
fait pas la meilleure situation pour one
+ france qui va faire son lancement et
qui n'a pas forcément envie que tout de
suite on aujourd'hui en tout cas la
presse française en parle j'ai vous des
articles de blog moi j'en parle en vidéo
et bien évidemment je n'essaye pas
forcément la situation la plus
confortable mais néanmoins il est là je
ne pouvais pas ne pas vous en parler
donc je suis très heureux de pouvoir le
faire aujourd'hui j'espère que ça vous
aura intéressé dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous l'attendez ce
smartphone est ce que vous avez à qu'on
vienne voir ce que ça raconte au niveau
de la vidéo au niveau de la photo le
rendu de test complet et est ce que vous
aimez one placé est ce qu'il vous fait
de l'oeil ce one piece profitent le
moins en bas en commentaire on se
retrouve très très vite et puis je vous
invite à venir vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas comme ça vous serez un
dès qu'on en parlera pour ça vous
accédez les petites cloches et même si
vous êtes déjà abonné pensée actionner
la cloche pour intensifier avec une
prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
chouette allez je vous embrasse pour les
soins bio et à très bientôt
[Musique]